in this video you're going to learn how
to solve triangles using the law of
sines and the law of cosines so when do
you use the law of sines in law of
cosines well it's when you don't have a
right triangle and we're gonna be using
these formulas right here I'm gonna go
through two examples with you the first
one's just gonna use the law of sines
the second ones we're gonna have to use
both the law of sines and the law of
cosines so you're gonna want to see that
both of these examples the first thing
though you want to notice though is that
you see how they have this angle 97
degrees in the side across from at 8 and
here we have 40 degrees but we don't
know the side across from it so how are
we going to find this missing side well
that's where the law of sines comes in
you can use you to this top one or this
bottom one they're just reciprocals of
one another so let's go ahead and set
this up we've got the sine of 40 degrees
over its side opposite I'm going to call
that side a because it's across from
angle a and that equals the ratio of the
sine of 97 degrees over its side
opposite which is 8 so now all we have
to do is cross multiply on the diagonals
that's going to give us 8 times the sine
of 40 degrees equals a times the sine of
97 degrees to get any by itself we just
have to do the opposite of multiplying
by 97 divided by the sine of 97 and
let's see what that comes out on our
calculators now you might want to make
sure you check your mode and make sure
you're in degrees so 8 sine 40 divided
by sine of 97 and that's coming out to
about 5.2 I'm just going to round so a
equals 5.2 now when we talk about
solving triangles what that means is we
want to find all the angles and all the
sides so there's actually six pieces of
information here let's solve for this
angle see here next we have these two
angles we can add them up and subtract
from 180 to find the third so 40 plus 97
is 137 and if we subtract that from 180
we get 43 degrees okay just one side
left to solve for that's the side across
from angle C okay which is side C so you
can see we have another pair and let's
make another proportion we have sine of
43 degrees over its side opposite C
equals sine of 97 degrees over its side
opposite which is 8 now you might be
saying Mario how come you didn't use 40
and 5.2 and the reason I do that is
because five
point two we actually round in that I
answer and so if we round again on this
next step we're gonna might be a little
bit off so I tend to try to go ahead and
use the original numbers if at all
possible
so now what we're going to do is we're
just going to get C by itself and so
again I'm going to cross multiply across
that equal sign so we have C times the
sine of 97 degrees equals eight times
the sine of 43 degrees and then divide
both sides by sine of 97 degrees to get
C by itself and check my calculator work
on this we've got eight sine of 43
divided by the sine of 97 okay so I'm
getting five point five for side C and
you solve the triangle you found all the
angles all the sides
example number two we've got this side
this side and the angle in between now I
want to point out something very
important to you if you try to do the
law of sines like sine of 120 degrees
over side B and then you try to do like
the sine of angle a over like nine
you're gonna have two unknowns two
variables and you're not gonna be able
to solve that equation so we're not
gonna be able to use the law of sines on
this problem whenever they give you side
side side like three sides and nothing
else or side angle side meaning the
angle in between the two sides that's
what you're gonna have to start off by
using the law of cosines and that's
these three formulas right here so what
we're gonna do is I'm going to use this
middle formula here because I'm trying
to solve for the side across from angle
D and I know the two sides that make up
angle B so we're gonna use this middle
one I'm just gonna rewrite it real
quickly here we've got B squared equals
a squared plus C squared minus 2 AC
cosine angle B okay so now let's go
ahead and substitute in what we know so
we don't know what side B is here so
let's just leave that as B squared a is
a side across from angle a so that's
going to be 9 squared C is the one
across from angle C that's 7 squared
minus 2 times 9 times 7 times the cosine
of angle B which is 120 degrees now to
solve for B see how this is B squared we
can take the square root of both sides
and that'll be what B is now check my
work on this we're gonna do this all I'm
gonna do it all in one step on the
calculator so we're gonna take the
square root of the quantity nine squared
plus seven squared minus two times nine
times seven times the cosine of 120 and
again make sure you're in degrees I'm
getting about thirteen point nine for
side B here so let's go ahead and put
that in so now what we're gonna do is we
can switch gears we can go over to law
of sines because you can see we've got a
pair now we've got 120 and thirteen
point nine and we're gonna solve for
angle a and side nine we could do at
angle C first as well but let's just do
angle a so we've got sine of angle a
over its side opposite which is nine
equals the sine of 120 degrees over its
side opposite which is thirteen point
nine now here I'm going to do I'm gonna
get sine of a by itself I'm gonna
multiply both sides by nine to get sine
of a by itself then what we're gonna
have to do is whenever you solve for the
missing angle you're gonna have to do
the sine inverse okay of both sides so
I'm gonna figure out what this is I'm
gonna take the sine inverse of it or you
can do it all in one step I tend to do
it in two steps so we've got nine times
a sine 120 divided by thirteen point
nine and then I'm gonna do the sine
inverse of that previous answer so I try
to take that whole long decimal so I get
a little bit more accuracy I'm getting
about thirty four point one for angle a
which is right here thirty four point
one degrees now you can see we've got
two of the angles to find the third
angle all we have to do is subtract from
180 degrees let's see we get a one
hundred fifty four point one so what's a
hundred and eighty minus one hundred
fifty four point one twenty-five foot
nine and that's it so now you solve the
triangle you found all the angles all
the sides and you got it if you want to
see what happens when you have like the
potential for getting two triangles or
one triangle or even no triangle follow
me over to that video right there where
I talk about that important concept of
the ambiguous case or the side side
angle condition